hello everybody hope that you're are
good Bitcoin is moving up and it's not
catching Us by surprise because this is
what we've been talking in the last two
videos we went through ethereum let's go
back to ethereum yesterday we were
saying that ethereum was only 1 to 5%
what 1 to 3% away from the range highs
it was so close to the range highs that
I was going to test it whereas Bitcoin
was pretty much the double away from it
it was around 2 to 5% 2 to 60% okay and
if ethereum was going to test the rent
highs why is Bitcoin not going to do the
same okay and that was telling us that
perhaps ethereum was a living indicator
of what Bitcoin was going to do next
okay that was the first idea then of
course we also went through the order
book The liquidity was to the upside you
guys remember those two red bars at
44,000 and
43,500 those two red bars have been hit
because current price is
44,700 also the liquidation hit map guys
you remember one mon time frame what
happened at
44,00 we're going to have a look at it
in a moment okay but all this
liquidations all that liquidity has been
absorbed by the market maker
now okay now the retail Trader this is
what we're talking yesterday's video now
the trader is looking at this pant here
okay for them it's a continuation
pattern and the market maker likes to
play with this okay is it going to give
the full pattern I mean sometimes it has
to but other times he won't okay because
if he never give this pattern then the
retail Trader is going to stop looking
at this okay so sometimes yeah the r
Trader has to win but overall the market
maker wins so the question is are we
going to see this pattern playing out
and fill the week straight away it's
possible okay or are we going to
see this pattern okay the the market
making pattern and that would mean that
this is is basically a fake out and then
we're going to drop to the range lows
retrace this liquidity pool and because
this week hasn't been filled and this
liquidity pool hasn't been fully
retraced this would be a good place to
long for us if we get this pattern okay
because yes I mean I believe that it's
likely that we break to the downside of
this pattern of this range I mean sorry
but in the meantime if we have a weak to
the upside that weak needs to get filled
first okay so uh you guys probably
remember
a chart that I posted a few weeks ago
and I was talking about barding a
scenario that it's basically something
like this okay some consolidation like
this until we break down from the range
and test this support here at 36k okay
and so far that's what it's playing out
boring scenario guys boring scenario why
is still in the range and now we at the
range
highs make or break and this is a very
important level because this is going to
decide whether if we want to see this uh
failed pant pattern I'm want to go to
the range lows okay or if you're going
to actually see some continuation to the
upsite and fill the wig directly okay so
for that there are a few things that I
want to uh pay attention to the first
thing is the daily time frame if we
close today's Candlestick at midnight
UTC time below the range size that'll be
telling me that is the fake out
okay that'll be telling me that is the
fake out and then we're going to go down
to the range lows so that's the first
thing okay a close below a daily close
below the range
highs for me pretty much confirms this
is a a fake out and we're going to go to
the range slows in the other hand if you
go to the 4 hours time frame we can
already start to
see candles closing above the range
highs okay and this is very good so
let's see if this continues because of
course right now we're in the London
session and as has pretty much held here
okay this pump was during um the the New
York session then Asia held London is
pretty much not doing much to be honest
this is London okay let me Mark you what
London's doing so
far this here is London so really not
much they rise price now a they retrace
so I mean it's still has an hour and a
half left about pretty much nothing is
happening um and when I upload this
video is probably going to be the start
of the New York session and that it's
going to be the most important s of the
day because if in the 4 hours time frame
we start to see more candlesticks
closing above the range highs that'll be
telling you that testing the support to
send it higher okay and potentially
we're going to retrace this liquidity
pool over here and of course the Weck
okay so very important level in the
chart I said yesterday in tweeted in the
YouTube videos blah blah blah range
Highs are very important right now okay
and it's going to decide what's going to
happen
next we're going to go now to the order
book we're also going to go to High
block Capital so meet you there high
block Capital 7 Days time frame let's
check this out look at that guys all the
liquidity is taken okay remember that
we've been talking for this about this
liquidity between
43,6 and 44
,700 well it's all taken now okay and
now once it's taken the market maker is
consolidating price you can see that
there hasn't been a consolidation this
long in these two levels okay because
the aim was is still higher to get the
liquidity above of this Z okay around
44,700 but now that it's taking the
liquidity the market make it is
consolidating price because they're
trying to decide what's going to be the
next most efficient move is it going to
be to the upside or to the downside
well let's see what the trader does
first that's probably what they are
thinking okay because yes if you run
again this map what the what is this I
don't know what I've click I'm sorry let
me see this
again okay um if you if you check this
out now you can see that the liquidity
to the upsite is still quite far away
it's a 47,000 next okay now if they
consolidate
price maybe ret Trader starts to jump
into shorts the liquidity here increases
and then they might have another reason
to increase prices okay not just to fill
that week or that retra that liquidity
pool but also because there are going to
be new liquidations up in there okay but
so far you know they are chilling there
is no much liquidity to the upsite
regarding liquidations of course just
regarding imbalances but regarding
liquidations nothing yet it's all taken
for now to the downside yes we still
have 4
1,350 okay that's pretty much a bit
above the range lows and that's an area
of Interest that's around also where the
liquidity pool
is if you check down the one month time
frame this is even more uh even more
clear look at this look at that yellow
bar
44,00 we talked about this also Monday's
video it's taken okay they took that
liquidity and now they are consolidating
to see what that to do next now if you
go to the liquidation levels this is
chart that I really
like okay let me change this settings to
Max
liquidity don't take the numbers with a
pinch of salt only as reference because
they are not real okay they are
obviously um inflated I don't know they
are obviously uh lower than it say so it
say $1 billion worth of long
liquidations at the moment this
basically telling you that the retail
Trader is mainly positioned into Longs
and this is also what we anticipated
yesterday why because there is a classic
pen and pattern that's a continuation
pattern for the retail Trader the retail
Trader trades based on conventional
trading patterns so it's quite normal
you know the the trader is mainly
positioning into Longs the problem that
they have is that they're probably going
to hold into those Longs and maybe
that's when the market maker decides to
reverse and hit their entry or their
stop loss because pay attention to these
spikes at the right of the chart you see
these spikes they're below the Cor
current price those are liquidation
points of long positions of high
leverage Traders all right
so there is a reason that the market
maker might might pull price down okay
hit this liquidations reset the chart
and then let's see what happens okay so
be very careful with this okay to me the
confirmation again would be in the daily
time frame if we close today's
Candlestick below the rain size that'll
be telling me guys that's a fake they
are playing with that pennant the market
maker is playing with that pennant okay
another the retail Trader the maret Mak
it is and then they will retrace price
back down hit all these liquidations all
these spikes reset the Delta
liquidations and everything is the same
as yesterday but they have more money
all right so uh be careful with that pay
attention to the Daily Candlestick if
know if that doesn't happen and any
actually closes above the
the r size then of course we're going to
see most likely continuation to the
upside we probably going to go towards
that liquidity pool and of course to
that Weck at 48k that needs to get filed
sooner or later right so I'm just
telling you what you need to to pay
attention to this is this is what I do
okay I have my levels in the chart that
I know how I want the candlesticks to
behave if they behave in a certain way
is telling me that this is going to
happen and if they behave in in this
different certain way then this
different thing is going to happen Okay
that's how I kind of trade well that's
how I analyze for me to then trade right
now let's go to the other book let's
let's see if we can get a hint of where
the liquidity is is still to the upside
or to the
downside this is the order book guys
okay in very short time frame that's why
you cannot see the uh Red Bar at 44k and
43,500 that we had yesterday now
absorbed because you see this is in very
short time frame okay um so uh it's
basically showing us where the liquidity
is currently at and you guys can see is
still saying to the upside 45k 46k what
those orders are
45k and 46k cuz if you notice those are
round numbers so are those limit sell
orders from the retail Trader because
yes the retail Trader is not going to
have ass short a
44,8 75. 60 so I have it at 45k at a
round number okay that's this this is
simply how our mind works okay we like
round numbers so my logic tells me that
those are possibly sell orders I mean
it's probably going to be a few take
profits there of you know the the less
greedy retails but I have the feeling
that with these last candles that we've
seen this scen candles then retail
Trader might be too excited and Rise
their take profit level a lot higher
okay so
possibly I don't think those are
liquidations because we haven't seen
those liquidations into in any chart
okay in high block so those can of be
liquidations can it be stop
losses at
45k could be stop losses of Traders are
trying that trying to to short the range
Highs but I idea because we're above
range highight so um I don't think there
are stop losses to be honest because you
know we haven't tested a resistance like
we literally broke the resistance and we
are above it so in my opinion they have
to be sell orders at 45k are those sell
orders going to be big enough to do
price 203 Bitcoins it says there you can
see that okay at the right of 45k tells
you 23.3 23.3 Bitcoin worth of short
orders not enough to me at least okay so
yeah maybe Market maker pushes price to
45k at least to absorve all those sell
orders then that could fuel the move to
continue Rising prices towards that
liquidity pool towards that week at 48k
while they are trapping already these
Traders okay so now that we've got all
this information from the other book
from high Capital we're going to go back
to the Chart we're want to make a plan
okay we are back in the chart and we're
going to try to make sense of all the
information that we've seen from the
book from hylock and from the chart
itself okay so the first thing that I
want to say is that if we go to the
Daily time frame and we see today's
Candlestick today's daily Candlestick
this green candle at the moment closing
below the range highs that that'll be
telling me that this is in play okay and
this would be go back to the forest time
frame guys that would be a fake out this
fake out and then a pull back back into
the range lows where uh to be honest if
that happens I'll be uh preparing here I
be building here a long position okay to
attack this week over here because yeah
I mean this is a huge imbalance that
needs to get filled soon or later so um
that'll be my Target and that's possibly
around the 20% 20% move for Bitcoin okay
if we target the 50% of the week which
is where I would take most of my profit
so if that happens then uh I mean it
wouldn't be a bad thing to see this drop
okay of course it would be quite nasty
this is a how much a drop it's around a
10% drop this could happen over a a week
or two weeks but if that happens nothing
bad okay because you still have this
week to the upside that needs to get
filled so this could be a good area a
good opportunity to load up again
towards that Z okay um at the end in my
opinion this is not an uptrend we've
been in a consolidation Zone in a
sideways Zone after a push up after an
uptrend for the last two months look at
this this is started this range started
the 5th of December this is not an up
Trend guys this is a range is
consolidation okay and this range can
last for another month why not and there
is a lot of good opportunities inside
this range so um embrace the range guys
embrace the range now let me remove this
cuz we've already talked about that
scenario if you guys remember we've seen
in the other book a level
45,000 with a a lot of sell orders well
that's what I think okay that's that's
my um interpretation of the order book
because it doesn't make sense that there
are stop losses because the retail
Trader that has
shorts at the range
SI I mean it wouldn't make any sense
literally because we we went straight
away back above it okay so it's been
tested as support it wouldn't make any
sense to open shorts okay if for example
price was hitting look let me let me
move this line okay imagine this was the
range highs then it makes sense that
those are the stop losses okay because
we are testing our resistance the retail
Trader knows that and they're going to
open shorts and then they're want to
have the the stop loss is here but right
now it's not the case this is the case
okay it cannot be a stop losses in my
opinion those are not liquidations
neither because we haven't seen that
information in high block Capital so to
me the only reason is that they are sell
orders which also makes sense because
it's a psychological level
45,000 and that is how the retail
Traders might work okay I long a 40K and
then I sell at 45k for example okay so
uh that's what I think now those sell
orders could be
fuel for for the price to continue
Rising higher okay because as you can
see right now in the 4-Hour time frame
which is a quite strong time frame we're
only seeing candlesticks closing above
the range size and testing our support
which is a very good thing let's say
what New York has prepared for us today
but if that's the case okay and even if
we come low again and we continue
testing the range SI of support that's a
very good sign that we are going to see
continuation now New York might a
straight away hit those sell orders and
that could basically add fuel to the
chart to continue PRI pushing price
higher retrace this liquidity pool and
even go stra away for this week at
48k okay and that is pretty much from
here from
45k that is pretty much a 6 to 5% move
okay so that's basically what I'm paying
attention
to uh so far I don't see um any VAR
signs let's wait for the daily
Candlestick to close maybe that changes
okay because if we close below the range
highs in the daily time frame then
that's a Bish sign but so far for our
time frame it's not s anything negative
okay we are above support right now
continue testing our support or even
send price from here from 45k absorb for
that liquidity continue pushing price
higher all right guys so I hope the
video is very clear um this is what I'm
attempting with this videos I want that
you guys understand what it's in my mind
sometimes it's difficult to to to
express but uh I'm trying okay so uh
thank you so much for watching guys and
I'll see you
soon